hello and welcome to Ed talks with Khan
Academy I'm Kristen deserva the chief
learning officer at Khan Academy and
today I'm excited to welcome Dr begonia
Viva who is a astrophysicist and the
lead systems engineer for two of the
instruments on the James Webb Telescope
and she was also the deputy lead for
operations during the commissioning of
all of the web instruments after launch
I'm so excited to have her with us today
before we get started I want to remind
you that Khan Academy is a non-profit
and we do rely on donations from folks
like you to keep doing the work we're
doing and you can go to donate.com
academy.org to donate and help keep us
moving and keep us working towards our
mission by a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere
I do want to thank some folks who helped
support us during the covid-19 crisis
including at T General Motors and fastly
next if you want to listen to this uh
interview on audio or if you want to
listen to other interviews we've done
you can go to homeroom with Sal the
podcast available wherever you get to
our podcasts and with that let me
welcome Dr begonia Villa welcome
hello Chris then uh so nice to be here
thank you for having me
your education Journey did you were you
always interested in space and and how
did you start out and how did you get to
where you are
uh well I grew up in Spain and we lived
outside a big city so the skies were
very dark so I remember when I was
little I was fascinated about the
changing on the sky at night right the
different stars the constellations and
even during the day you know the Sun and
then the moon faces
um I I at that time I didn't know there
was a career such as astrophysics that I
I would be able to do so then I did my
studies I was a good student and then I
started in physics and follow my at 46th
degree on my PhD on that field and and
then progressed from there as you
mentioned from being in the University
as a researcher to move into the private
sector uh working to build some of these
satellites and observatories that we are
going to launch and and do the systems
engineering so and that has been my path
so of level to get here it's great were
there particular teachers or courses
that you really enjoyed or were
influential for you
yes for sure I loved all the topics I
think I still do obviously I love
physics and math but I also love history
and and lots of other things and in
those days in Spain
um you I was going to a Catholic school
and they were all girls right and the
teachers were all women but I do
remember my physics teacher she was not
a nan but she was a a woman and she was
attractive and she was very good at
physics so I think that helped me a
little bit to know that being a woman or
being a girl you know you can you can
combine both things and then later on
once I started on the higher degrees
where it was a mixed class with boys and
girls there was also my physics teacher
was really good
um and I think that's so important right
when we have this uh teachers or these
people on our lives that are good at
what they do and explain things well and
we relate to I think there's such a a
good encouragement to keep us going on
the path we want to pursue so definitely
I have had good support throughout which
is very lucky
great
so give us your your Quick Pitch about
the James Webb Telescope what makes it
unique
yes for sure it's the biggest largest
telescope we have launched into space up
to now and I think it's Unique in two
ways it's Unique on the engineering part
and is unique on the science on the
engineering part the scientists wanted a
telescope that could look back in time
to the first galaxies and stars that
form in the universe and see how they
changed to become the planet the Galaxy
where we live and also they wanted to
keep looking for a Life as we know it in
other planets right if we talked maybe
uh 50 years ago we could ask you know do
you think there are planets around other
stars apart from our own and we we could
have opinions about it now we have had
some telescopes out there Kepler and
tests that have shown yes other stars
have planets we think now maybe every
Star has planets so web can continue to
look for those planets but it can move
things a little bit forward which is do
those planets have an atmosphere and if
they have an atmosphere that's that
atmosphere look like the one from Earth
you know we still don't know if they
have Life as we know it but it's a
little bit moving in that direction so
from the science obviously this
wonderful discoveries but to achieve all
that
um we needed a big mirror to collect
more light and see be able to see so far
back in time and uh we also needed to
look into a particular wavelength maybe
we'll talk about that later which is
called the infrared it's not the visible
light like our eyes so infrared is heat
so we needed to be able to cool this
telescope so we needed a big sun shield
a bit like a beach umbrella to keep us
cold and those two the big mirror and
the big sand Shield were great Concepts
but they didn't fit in the rocket that
we have to use for the launch so web is
the first telescope that we had to fold
to fit in the rocket and open once we
are in a space deploy it so that was a
big achievement on the engineering side
that we opened the path for future
missions been being able to do the same
so I think it's wonderful on both sides
the science and the engineering for this
this Observatory
I love that balance between the two so
tell us about your role what do you do
uh well so I started with the Canadian
space agency uh this Observatory is an
international collaboration which is one
of the super cool things about it it has
contributions from Europe from the
European Space Agency contributions for
NASA obviously and and University and
companies in the U.S and then
contribution from the Canadian space
agency so I started in Canada
um working on the two instruments that
are the contribution one of them is a
science instrument that we call nearest
and the other instrument is the fine
guidance sensor so the sense that sensor
is the one that's going to allow that
the observatory can point correctly to
what it should be in a space and then
keep the observatory stable meaning when
we are taking an image or on a Spectra
like when we take a photo with a camera
here on the ground if you're moving the
camera the picture is going to not look
very good so you have to do the same
with something you have to keep the
cameras steady so that instrument
doesn't do the science yet but it keeps
the observatory stable so I started
working in Canada and when we built what
we call the flight model the final model
that's going to go into space and those
are going to be delivered to NASA I move
to work directly for NASA which was
really a cool a great experience for me
and then I could take a little bit of a
bigger role I could be involved on some
of the testing of all the instruments on
some of the planning of that testing and
then on the activities needed to
commission that Observatory once we were
on orbit and and to continue now
shadowing a little bit how the guider is
doing for for its operation so I have
been very lucky to to be part of this
Observatory for 16 years so I'm very
excited that we are very where we are
now
yes yes you can look back I'm sure on
how far you've come
so it kind of blows my mind to think
about holding holding this stable in
space when I think about you know in my
head you think about things kind of
floating around and and how do you make
something stable so you can get a clear
picture
ah yes so every
um Observatory that you launch any
satellite will have these star trackers
that keep track of where the stars are
right in the sky and I will point it uh
to a certain position but then you
really need to to get the accuracy so
what the guidance instrument does is it
takes an image of that part of the sky
and is looking for a particular star
that the catalog from the ground tells
us to find find this star and once you
find it keep it in this position and
keep it there super stable so what we do
is we provide the position of data star
very accurately six times every second
and there is an algorithm that keeps
checking if we tell you that position
has changed a tiny bit uh there is a
mirror that's going to move to bring the
the position exactly where it should be
and we do it those 16 times every second
the instruments that take images in a
longer period of time they can take 10
seconds to take an image so we are able
to keep that Precision so they don't
even notice any any small movement that
that we catch so it's a kind of closed
loop operation where I tell you
something and you react to what I tell
you and then I tell you what I see then
and and is this process that we have
um optimized for for web and of course
you have to work if you think about the
sky there are parts of the sky where
there is only a few Stars some where
there are hundreds of stars somewhere
the stars are very dim very faint some
where they are very bright so we have to
have different take all that into
account in the algorithm so you know it
works well every time or as many times
as we can make it on the first attempt
so
yeah yeah so it seems like you're doing
kind of a combination of engineering and
science do you think of yourself and
both of those spaces
yes I think I consider myself very lucky
because I love astronomy I love
astrophysics uh that's that was my kind
of my first love and that's what I
pursue right in my career where I did my
PhD and my research and I was interested
on Galaxy's right I was looking at
this spiral galaxies like our own where
you have arms around the center and the
arms are rotating and at that time when
I was doing my PhD we already knew uh
thanks to another astronomer called
viraruving very famous that if if we
were looking at the rotation of those
arms uh they were moving faster than we
expected when you were feather away that
was the first indication that there is
some matter there in the universe that
we don't know what it is this dark
matter and this dark energy right
um so I was doing research I I had a
postdoctoral position in universities in
United Kingdom but the problem at that
time is is difficult a little bit to
find a permanent position on on a
university you can do a disposed
doctoral
positions for three years and then maybe
you move to another University
um and then as a family we moved to
Canada and at that time
it was a more stable option for me to go
to the private sector but I still wanted
to be involved in a space and a new
research so I looked for a company that
will work on on launching observatories
for astronomy into space and then I
believe I have still been able to use my
knowledge in astronomy because you have
to work with the scientists that want
this instrument to know what they what
they need and be able to meet those
needs and you also appreciate the
science the reasons why you are doing
this Observatory and you get equally
excited about what we are going to find
out so I consider myself very lucky that
I have the astronomy background but I
also was able to grow in this role as a
systems engineer where you are looking
at the big picture and how you can make
uh those scientific goals come to life
so yeah it's and maybe for the for the
for those in the audience you can see
you you can think you want to do
something when you are younger I think
anything you learn is so exciting that
you learn it and and and then but you
you can change your mind you can decide
I thought I would love this and I have
loved it but for whatever reason I'm
going to try something new uh it's never
lost I mean you have a knowledge with
you and an experience that will probably
benefit the next thing you are looking
for so I think through life all of us
kind of move and and and get to where we
are meant to be or what we like to do
through different paths so I think
that's always very important to keep
moving forward
yeah yeah absolutely I had someone who
told me it's easy to look back and
explain the path of how you got to where
you are but sometimes when you're moving
forward it's not always clear where
you're going next but you can keep
building on where you are so yeah
and sometimes yeah and sometimes you're
looking for something right you're
looking for an opportunity and we all
have moments where something doesn't
materialize we thought we would really
like to do this and for whatever reason
you know we don't get that and at the
time is disappointing for sure but you
know it's these kind of things that we
save something doesn't happen
um if you pursue and continue uh you'll
find something else and then as you say
maybe looking back you'll go well
actually you know I thought I really
wanted that but maybe this other path is
good so I know we all get discouraged
sometimes with different uh through our
life but I think the important thing is
to not notice parents say well that
didn't work let me try something else
and in the long run as you say looking
back maybe everything was for the better
or even if it didn't seem like it that
night
absolutely absolutely all right so let's
talk a little bit more about the
telescope you talked about pointing and
where it is how do you decide what to
point it at
hey that's a very good question so uh of
course you you have to decide where what
you're going to study right uh so uh the
team that took part on building the
observatory uh they have a what they
call guarantee time right if you were
part of the bill the scientists that
were involved will have a little bit of
time that when you launch you have these
activities that you want to observe and
and you will have the time but then the
rest of the time is for everybody this
is an observatory for the whole world so
anybody can submit a proposal you you
have a great idea you you can say well I
want to look at this part of the sky
because I know stars are being formed
there or because I know there are some
bending of the light I know there are
very far away galaxies there or maybe I
want to look at this particular planet
or or
um you you will have an interest as an
astronomer so you have to put a proposal
what we call a proposal and you indicate
what you would like to observe and then
there is a team of scientists that will
gather all those proposals and decide
which ones are worthier you know for
multiple reasons which ones will give
the better science and of course any
observatory in the space is overly
subscribed on web is as well but then
those proposals are selected and then
there is another team that coordinate
them to observe throughout the year you
don't want to be moving the observator
you know today here and then tomorrow I
come back the other way you want to be
as efficient as possible so there is a
team dedicated to that I will say we
have the proposals approved for this
year and we are going to order them such
that we are maximizing the observation
time for the year and that was on for
the first year and now just now the uh
proposal request is open for year two so
any astronomers can now submit their
what they would like to observe and
again there will be a process to uh
select the word yes I'm sure they're all
going to be very good but with the time
that can be fitted on that year for the
observations
wow that is fascinating so we just were
showing some of the images that we see
and they I mean they look like art
coming back but what are some of the
things that people are learning from
them from the scientific point of view
absolutely I know we were um and you
know we had launched we we are the
observatory is 1.5 million miles away
four times the distance of the Moon and
it took us a month to get there and we
had a complicated process where we had
to what we said before deployed and then
we have to open those mirrors then we
had to align the mirrors then we had to
turn the instruments calibrate and salt
together it was six months but even
during that time to to calibrate and
align the mirrors we were taking images
right to be able to do that and we could
already sense even without it being
fully calibrated how wonderful the
images were and we were all waiting even
us with weighted breath for those first
images that you are seeing some of them
there you can see uh here uh the Stellar
Cliffs right so this is one of my
favorite images and I think for other
people
so people are looking so we're looking
for places where stars are being formed
right and those stars when they form
um some of them in this image some of
those Stars will be forming but they
have an uh acquired enough Mass to start
shining yet but some of them are shining
when they start shining when they start
doing the nuclear reaction like our sun
does then they generate a lot of energy
that pushes the gazas around them you
need that gas to form other stars so
that nebula shows those newborn Stars
pushing the gas away but that pushing of
the gas compresses some of that gas and
allows other stars to form so it's an
area of active star formation and we
know some of those Stars will have
planets forming around them so lots to
be learned about that place where where
stars are being formed and you saw
another image which was this planetary
nebula this big ring around uh I start
in the center is actually two stars and
that's the opposite end that's the star
that's dying right when a star dies it
dies in this big explosion which is a
supernova and he generates these rings
that we can see on that Saturn Ring
Nebula the one we are seeing now and you
can see there all these shock waves that
were formed and this is very important
because we know the first stars that
form in the universe were much bigger
than our sun maybe a hundred times a
more massive and those Stars at the
beginning only had hydrogen and helium
to it that's the elements that were
there a little bit of the ethereum but
when they explode on this big Supernova
they are able to generate them the extra
elements that we need carbon oxygen all
the elements of the periodic table so
the next stars that are formed have
these extra elements and this is a
process that gets repeated for millions
and billions of years until and that we
know we need because we are made of
those elements so we know uh you know
when they say we are made of dust of
stars is totally true we needed those
first stars and over time to give this
richness to the the medium that
eventually allowed us to be there so all
of all of that for sure the star
formation star Evolution uh you saw that
other super cool image which is the
first one that President Biden selected
that is looking back in time to those
very old galaxies in there we have one
of the oldest galaxies today that has
been found uh for by web which was born
or generated only a few a million years
after the big band so a web has found
for now the oldest Galaxy on that image
we can also see these little arcs which
are kind of what we call lensing that's
starring a galaxy in the background that
whose light gets bended so there is that
that information there
um and then
um
you saw briefly there tell us about the
time about what what time what what time
are we seeing here so you talked about
this being able to see in the past and
what that is like yeah
we keep saying we can look back in time
right which is such a strange thing so
uh we can look back you know there was a
big bang the universe universe was
formed first it was very hot and nothing
could form but eventually cool down and
we think about 300 million years after
that big bound it was called enough that
the little particles started to be able
to Clump together and that eventually
led to the formation of this initial
Galaxy's initial stars and then
Evolution started but how can we see
that well and those first stars and
galaxies uh shine an emitted light right
and that light has been traveling for
billions of years in a universe that is
expanding the universe is stretching so
the fact that that universe is expanded
means that this light as it travels its
wavelength stretches so when we say the
wavelength stretches it just means it
moves on the on the spectrum of light
that we can see it moves to another part
of the spectrum it moves to the infrared
so with our eyes we can see the visible
right we can see the what we see on on
the universe with our eyes is this
visible part
and in there you won't see these objects
because their light has moved so that's
why web was designed to move and look on
these infrared part so when you take a
picture there then you are kind of
collecting that light that has been
traveling all that time and be able to
then take pictures of this very early
objects that that pictures you take is
how those objects were when they emitted
that line which was many billions of
years away so that's how web is able to
to look back in time in a way
[Laughter]
yeah that is crazy oh my goodness I know
and um yeah go ahead
I know we have been talking about things
very far away but I think lately you
have seen uh that web can also look at
our solar system right we have seen
super cool images of Saturn of Jupiter
uh and there are some more that are
coming out uh and um so web can also see
which is very important can see on our
solar system anything that's feather
away than the earth uh and this is also
tricky to do because we design a
telescope that wanted to look for very
faint things and now you're looking at
something that's on our neighborhood
they are in our neighbor so those
objects are really bright on our cameras
so we have to use a different technique
and be able to look at at the solar
system and and the guide instrument as
well has to do something different so
each of the images looking in our
neighborhood versus looking far away
requires a different systems on the
observatory and that's something that
also had to be developed and you can see
now some of those amazing images that
are going to help us study uh the where
we are right this is the solar system
closer to us and we are going to learn a
lot again about how how we can to be how
a solar system like this is being born
and and some of the moons in our solar
system we know they have eyes you know
some of the moons in Saturn and Jupiter
are icy worlds and and we know where
there is water we know we life on earth
started on water so anywhere where we
see water is of interest to
astrobiologists and other because it's a
clue I mean how to again understandably
better how they how we came to be where
we are now so
yeah so do you think we're gonna find
life someplace uh someplace out there
other than Earth
well I think I mean we are a special I
think Earth is a special right we we
have seen um is not easy to find a
planet and and you can see on our solar
system we are the only example so I do
think we are a special but on the other
hand uh there are billions of stars
there and um and each of them having uh
planets so I am optimistic that we will
find uh some signs of life on other
planets of course
um we are they will be very far away so
we need this Young Generation that are
listening to us we need to be able to
travel uh feather than the solar system
so we need lots of new expertise to to
take us there but I do think that there
will be
um somewhere there might be a life like
we know it in this huge universe that we
are part of yes
yeah we have a question from YouTube
from mayor about how are things that the
new things that we get to learn in
astronomy helpful for us are there
things that we're learning that are you
know helping us in our lives
yes I think
um
two parts on this right to be able to go
into space uh we have to develop lots of
technologies that then get used on on
bias right so these developments that we
have on computers on on fonts
um some of the materials that we work
with on on the ground now and some of
the Technologies like the Lasik that we
use for correcting eyes are things that
were developed to be able to put things
in a space that were lighter or that we
could communicate better or that we
could download lots of data Etc so there
is always applications that come down to
to the Earth and that we use every day
the UPS lots of things that we take for
granted now came from our desire to
explore the space but also I believe
it's part of in my opinion of what we
are as humans right we want to know I
believe how to understand our world
where we live but I think we also want
to know how we came here and how we can
evolved and how we can continue to
explore our universe I think we have we
have explored the Earth we continue to
do so but I don't think we are limited
to this earth only so I think it's
um it's very useful to learn uh all of
these things and to continue looking
forward and advancing our understanding
of the universe like you know relativity
and lots of things like that that we
wouldn't have known unless we are
looking at the universe and this bigger
scale
um and and that we are trying to
understand so I think it's important to
keep learning and yeah at the big side
and on the little side as well on the
small
small world of quantum physics the
gravity and the universe around yeah
yeah we have a couple of couplings that
are kind of related to climate
climate warming are there things we can
learn about our own atmosphere or the
things that you know on Earth from some
of the things that we're learning
yes so of course I'm talking about a
telescope that's looking for astronomy
you know the universe how how are things
happening how how the things evolve for
our solar system right how how are
things interacting but there are other
um many other telescopes launched into
space that are looking at our atmosphere
the atmosphere of the earth and we share
some of their research to do
um those observations and of course
those are the ones that we used to
monitor the awesome layer the the carbon
dioxide and and it is very important
that we know that this is happening to
you know to tell us that we do have to
look better after our planet we have a
grown technologically very fast since
the first satellite that was launched
Sputnik which I believe was 1957 in a
very short amount of time and we have
learned a lot and the industrial
Revolution as well from the beginning of
this Century we have grown a lot and our
our planet I don't think is not designed
for this kind of growth so I I do think
we have to
um do better to look after the planet
where we live because is is the one we
have we we don't have other so I think
all of these things are always very
important to to learn and and do better
on the planet that we have
um yeah yeah
we are already at the half hour so let
me ask one more question what is
something that you're looking forward to
or that we might look forward to from
the telescope to come
yeah so again we know we know the big
themes right the things that we are
studying and we are seeing these amazing
images uh I think we are all looking for
something that we won't understand right
as the scientists keep uh analyzing the
data and taking data
um I think we are looking for this
little surprise that maybe will show us
something that we don't understand to
start with but then as we learn it it
will it will show us something new and I
think that has been true of all the big
discoveries in astronomy right from
earlier on where we thought the Earth
was the center and everything turned
around and some of those early
astronomers were like uh I don't think
that's quite right right I mean there is
some data that I'm taking where I I
don't think that's true and to say okay
uh the Sun and how we understand how all
the planets move and then again some
astronomers said I don't know some of
those orbits we're finding something
there that we don't understand that
eventually we came up the effect of
gravity and the relativity and I think
that always happens I like to mention
you know I think maybe uh you know this
deep image from Havel uh the Deep Field
which uh is a part of the sky that when
we were looking at it from the earth it
looked dark there was nothing there and
when Hover was launched time was
allocated to observe it for many days I
think it was about 12 days to show that
if it's a dark part of the sky where
nothing is there and this is a very
famous image is the Deep Field image
from have aware oh and behold there are
thousands of galaxies there so we
realized that uh you know the universe
is not as we think so I think for web
even if great discoveries are going to
come you know we have found the oldest
Galaxy to date and we have found the
first exoplanet with with web as well
um and there are going to be these
wonderful discoveries but I think we're
all looking for something that we don't
quite understand to start with I think
that's how we that's how we learn and
and put our thinking cap on and and
think of something new uh to to
understand it
let's press the end
so much for joining us today
forward to what we're going to learn
next
thank you thank you for having me and I
want to encourage all the young kids you
know to pursue whatever whatever you
like and take it Forward I didn't
mention it but an observatory like this
one needs you know a mechanical
engineering electrical engineering
software engineering astronomers Optical
engineering so wherever you feel
something that you like just pursue it
and then you'll you'll become part of
great things that you might enjoy so go
forward
thank you so much and thanks everyone
for joining today we'll see you next
time